you recently announced a pretty big
purchase while everyone else is running
around and and worried about surviving
you guys announced that you're
purchasing coin market cap maybe just
talk a little bit about kind of how that
deal came together how you originally
met them and then kind of what the logic
behind the acquisition is sure so I've
known Brandon I've used mock coin market
caps for like I don't know ever like
from 2013-14 when they started back then
there was like a number of other sort of
data aggregators but they claimed market
cap just grew grown to be the most
popular one by far so and I so when we
after we started it was like basically
about two years ago I was just sort of
paying Brandon just sort of very very
occasionally not frequently just sort of
hey how you doing
so I mean I've been paying him overtime
with with a sort of interest of say
potentially working together more a
closer partnership actually in that
position I didn't sort of mentioned in
that terms I was just sort of table I
was just trying to understand what his
mental mentalities are and it was really
two words in the end of last year like a
few months ago we we we met again and we
kind of discussed and we both felt there
was an interest and so we we talked we
like I think we met over we met twice
and we sort sort of discussed the
numbers and we came to a term pretty
pretty quickly and it was a very simple
it was a very simple deal so it's like
there's no complicated stuff going on
and and then from there we're just like
getting lawyers to execute the deal
which took a while but and none of us
went back like none of us thought about
to renegotiate the terms of the deal
even in this economic turbulent times I
think like for me I'm looking at this
thing at a very very long term play it's
not like okay how much is it was today
or tomorrow the day the day before so we
don't think in that kind of terms where
I think look if we right now is what I
think is one of the most valuable as
platforms in the industry and I think we
you'll grow another
and X 100 X so I also I think the higher
value for that is not to make it just
service financed our complex change I
think she continued to grow the what its
original purpose providing data access
for crypto and beat-beat the landing
page of crypto have information on there
so I think which coin market cap will
continue to grow in that way and I
actually think that they have not been
expanding super aggressively because
it's a small team they've been growing
organically the selling ads etc right
look by what it was - we acquired and we
also have we also have more room to fund
it so I think we just want to continue
to fund the growth of it that's
naturally a lot of synergies with - comm
but we're not there's also naturally a
lot of synergies with every other
exchange out there so coin market cap
would continue to maintain neutrality
and independence and any other exchange
who wants to continue to work with them
I think most of moment definitely well
because they are by far the largest
single referral for any exchange so I
think and they will continue to work
with our biggest changes so that's fine
so that's kind of how the deal was went
together actually pretty simple got it
in in terms of Kennebunk we talked about
this 10x 100x expansion like what is
your vision at least I've come back past
like how do you actually 10x that is
that let's take the BAI Nance playbook
of kind of super aggressive growth and
just sense of of our folks over and help
them do that or is there something else
that's a little bit more complex and how
you do it sure I think actually thinks
that it's actually something much more
simpler I think we just got a wit for
the market I think basically in the
market industry doesn't grow then
unlikely for coin market cap to go 10x
or even for Bannister go 10x I think
like--look coin market caps by far the
largest data aggregator or and then I
provide our site and - dot-com is by is
one of the largest exchanges and both in
future spot margin so so I think but
like even if you kill all the other
industry players
we're now gonna go we're not gonna go
another I don't know 10x or med
definitely not 100x so I think the goal
is definitely to yeah we we buy for like
we're definitely over like 10% market
share you know a lot of places so we we
don't have room to grow 10x even make
sure everybody in those things so I
think the goal is to is to make the
industry bigger and and to make the
industry bigger we actually can't grow
alone we actually want to grow with
other industry players so we want other
exchanges to grow we want other better
data providers to grow information
providers to grow because this is like
100 200 different countries in the world
and a lot of different geographies
different cultures different banking
channels via channels etc there's only
so much we can do ourselves even though
we're the bigger we're warm the biggest
fairs in the market but we need to grow
the industry bigger we need other people
to do it with us so I think right now if
you look at the industry probably only
wine wine 1000 people have crypto so
this at least a thousand times to grow
but and even that is not a very good
measurement I think if you like if you
jerks the potential market share of taxi
or the the market size of taxis for uber
that's not the potential market size and
they're gonna expand our market so I
think Crito in crypto we're looking at
the same same thing acquittal we'll be
able to serve as new business types new
opportunities that the traditional Fiat
world does not does not touch or can it
cannot service so I think basically in
my mind the trick is really just to grow
the industry so it's not so much hey
let's give them more but we would
definitely want to I want them to hire
more grow the team I think the team's
too small and but other than that I
think we're just gonna continue to build
innovative products and provide services
that other people wants to use and
hopefully the industry will grow I'm not
pretty confident the industry won't grow
yeah obviously I'm there with you on
that one of the most asked questions I
got when I ask people for questions to
ask you and obviously you don't have to
answer this if you don't want but people
want to know how was the acquisition
paid for was the cash stock or B&B and I
said look I'll ask him but I don't think
he's going to answer that
so it's not that I don't want to answer
that part is covered by the NBA
so I actually can't answer it but it's a
it's a pretty straightforward deal so
there's nothing too complicated about it
and and to be honest I before us doesn't
matter what the method is so if if b and
b cash is the same thing if it's cash
cash b and b is cash or PT c is cash to
us when people say cash then problem in
u.s. dollars that's fine we will come if
we need that we can just we can just
sell BTC or sell B&B and convert to cash
this is the same thing to be honest and
yeah but it's a very straightforward
deal there's nothing complicated about
it one of the things that I think he you
said early on that I remember saying hey
I like that guy is you said look I got
no more fiat left right I spent it all
and get all crypto yes so but look if we
have to spend fiat then we just sell
some crypto and but we don't host yeah
so whatever fear we want we need to
spend we just sell crypto and we spend
it and we and then we'll have no fear
left again so that's kind of how we
operate